frustrados y desesperados hacen fila
durante horas con la esperanza de
conseguir recibir el precio del
controvertido medicamento antiviral se
ha disparado en los últimos días para
que los ciudadanos se apresuran a
conseguirlo desde ayer mis amigos mi
familia y yo hemos hecho unas 150 200
llamadas telefónicas pero nadie contesta
por moody's así que es un fallo de
sistema es transferible con los
pacientes al fijándose en los hospitales
por falta de suministro de oxígeno el
número de muertes en indias se acerca
rápidamente al sombrío hito de los
200.000 que muchos consideran no refleja
la realidad de la tragedia ya no queda
espacio en los crematorios la gente está
incinerando los cuerpos donde no
encuentra espacio incluso se han quedado
sin madera para quemarlos el primer lote
de ayuda médica de reino unido ha
llegado incluyendo 100 ventiladores y 95
concentradores de oxígeno francia
australia tailandia arabia saudita e
incluso los enemigos militares de india
pakistán y china también han ofrecido su
ayuda
eeuu finalmente está liberando materias
primas para fabricar vacunas y españa va
a enviar siete toneladas de suministro
médicos vamos a ser fieles a lo que
hemos venido manteniendo desde el inicio
de la pandemia nadie estará a salvo
hasta que todos estemos a salvo es
también nuestra forma de expresar un
compromiso solidario para con aquellos
países que hoy necesitan de la ayuda de
la comunidad internacional la crisis que
se agrava en índia podría tener
implicaciones mundiales ya que una nueva
variante local supone una mayor amenaza
y muchas naciones dependen de las dosis
de astrazéneca que se producen en el
país